>>> WE H
OUR POLITICS LEADLEMEP D CHAIR
WAS ARRESTODAYHAED TILLEGALLY L
B  ANDTRIED TO SWAE COMING ADMIZ
AN ARE FEDERAL
SPECIFLYBARRACK
Repor HE WAS
TIN BEHALF OF UAWITHOUT STERINGH
JUSTICE DEPAMENT AS A FOREIGN
AGENT.HAT'S WHAT HE'S CHARGED
WITH.
BUAM THAT
HE DID I
01 CANDIDATE DONALD
TR MAKING A SPEECH O
ENERGY AT TH
CLIENTS IN THEK GEDLY INSERTED
AI
PRESORND DELIVERED IS
IN ANO INS
BE,
APPARENTLY -- THPROVID
HE WAS A PROMINE VOICE FOR  REME
APPARY ONE OF THOSE,
THE EMIRAT SAYING,
ILTH TEAM,
WAS A REFERE UAE, NOT ED STATES.
N FOR THAT AT ONE POINT E PUSHIN
IABU DHABI.IN PROMOTE THAT
PERSON WITH THE ADMINITI A STAT
BARRACK'SPRSON WHO
QUOTE, FROM K HAHIMSELF VOLUNTAH
PLEADING NOT GUIY. OTHERS WERE T
TOM BARRACK.
WHATTHEM?
>> ONEKS I
BARRACK'S COMPANY.
E
PROSECUTORS FLED.
HE'S AN EMIRATE  A
CHARGED IN TCA.
PROSECUTOEDHEY I INETURNED TO
COTRTHE THINGS T
PROS IS
THAT HHESE
INTERNATIONAL TIES, D RHCAUSE OA
E ABOUT THIS WITH
G TO THE ONWIECURE MEAGAP
WITH THE PURPOSE FOR
VETHIS SOUND LIKLING CAS YOU?
>> IT DOES, JAKE.THE EVEN LOOKS.
46-PAGE INDI, IT
GOES INTGRREALLY THE MAIN IME H
THREE ONE, WAS B LOBBYING THE
ED STATES GOVERNMENT, AND
EVAN JUST LAIDN THE WAYS TT
N OF LOOKS LIKE DOJ HAS EMAILS .
AND,K FAIL TO
STH DOJ AS A F
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY HAV ME.
>> HE 7D. SAID T GUILTY
SPOKESMAN SA HE'S NOT GUILTY, D
BUT DO YOU THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT HE MIGHT TRY TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH PROSECURS?
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE, GENERALLY
YOURSELF TDUCE YOUR OWSK
I PROSECUTORS.
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IND IN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM, ANYONE WHO ASLL
EVERYTHING  ANYTHIN
ANYONE ELSE BE WILLING
TOHA
AT ONE POINTTEDLY MITTEEICH
BEING INVEAT
>> YOU SAY TTHIGENT CHHEHAFR
COME POSSIBLE PRISONIM
YEAH.
SOBARRACK IS ALSO CHARGED CEOF
MAKIIEALSE
STATEMENTS TO FBI AGENTS.
DEAN IN R
COMMAT
WORKING WITH
THEY HAVE EMAILS THAT CONTRADICT
THAT.
IT CAN CARRY A HIGHER PENALTY
THAN THE ACTIVATION.STRUCTION O
ST
EVENABLES A
KNEW HE WAS  GUILTY MIND.YHIS S
WHY ELSE WOULD E FBI?
>> NO ONE IN THEMPIGN OR THE AD
BEEN EVED IN THIS
TOM BARRACK WAS NOT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, ALTHOUGH HE
S NEWSGURA
U VEE INS TO TRUMPS?
>> YEAH, I THINK THERE TVELS OFP
AND OTHEOPBARRACK DOES FLIP,
DOES COORA INFORMATIONN HE GIVE?
AND NDL IT
QUESTIONS ABOUJUSTAREFUL
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS.
WERFUL, VERY HIGHLAND APPARENTLA